The ocean.
The largest habitat on Earth.
A generation ago, the serious the Blue Comet took us
beneath the waves.
But now we know so much more.
Take a deep breath.
technology. Allow us to voyage further.
And deeper than ever before.
From the restless shores about coastline.
I don't think speech to track their prey.
Troop enchanted undersea forests where fairy tale creatures dwell.
The costs vibrant coral cities bustling with ingenious inhabitants.
Into the vastness of the Big Blue tooth feels solution
Congress.
And down into uncharted depths where some of Earth's best
kept secrets find.
Coming soon untold stories from magical worlds.
This is Blue Planet II.